this is a production of Cornell
University
Thank You Don so obviously we're gonna
talk a little bit about berries today
that's what I do and that's what I've
been doing at Cornell now for 17 years
so I work in actually several different
species as you can see up here
raspberries strawberries and
blackberries
so Cornell has a long history of work in
berries at the station opened in 1882
and berries were one of the first fields
that were planted that first year at the
station in Geneva of course at that time
the station was an independent unit was
not part of Cornell but did join Cornell
in 1923 and that's that program has been
maintained through that time we are the
oldest berry breeding program in the
United States and as far as continuously
active as far as I could tell were the
oldest continuously active program in
the world but those stats are a little
hard to come by so there may be some
dispute there over that time our program
has developed 41 different raspberry
varieties three of which I have named
and and patented you can see them there
we've also developed 43 strawberry
varieties over that time the 43rd one
coming out today being announced today
in The Chronicle we did plan that a
little bit so but so generally I know
there has been some some blackberry
varieties there's been little work in
blackberries mainly because New York is
generally too cold to consistently grow
blackberries but that's changing with
some new genetics that we're using in
blackberries so my program and my
appointment is research and extension we
have a very diverse set of clientele
that we work for that we try to help
certainly the home gardeners gardening
is the number one hobby in the United
States of course can be done by people
of all ages and people continue to do it
throughout their lives and so our
varieties are certainly many of them are
suitable for home gardeners and they
really love berries there's nothing
better nothing better than a berry out
of your backyard it would be the
best-tasting berry you'll ever get
that said you can't grow berries in your
backyard all the time so we have the
people that cater to those home
gardeners certainly the retail nurseries
these are your companies like Burpee
seed company sell our varieties the
gardens alive company which is Gurney's
and Michigan bulb company and some of
those other catalog companies that sell
directly to the retail market generally
small numbers high price per plant you
get into the commercial nurseries
you might recognize nurseries like North
farms Crone farms in Michigan there's a
lot of berry nurseries around the
country we work directly with them with
our varieties license and dry varieties
but also working with them with new
material they propagate some of our
material to give out to growers for
grower trials before they're released
and so we have a very good relationship
with many of these growers around the
country and then commercial producers
both domestic and international we work
directly with the New York State berry
Growers Association
they provide member growers who will
test some of our material before it make
it to the marketplace as well as larger
companies in California that want to see
things pre commercialization so they can
be ahead of the game when it comes out
we have international cooperation as
well so we have it we have exclusive
contracts in Mexico in Europe and we're
working on a few other countries so that
they can see our material very quickly
and if there's something they like they
can bring it to the market before
everybody else and they can have it for
their own for their own programs for
their own production
so in the extension side of things we do
things like variety trials generally and
a lot of protect production technology
research
I worked quite a bit with Marvin of
course on that Marvin Pritz on that area
this is a project that Marvin led on low
tunnels for strawberries with a neutral
to extend the season it's been very very
successful and the berries look really
good under the system and we really we
think it's a very good option for the
New York grower so right now there are
strawberries available underneath these
low tunnels and people are still picking
strawberries where they have them and
they can pick strawberries through
generally through the mid-november is
how we find it often we just run out of
berries as it cools down but the quality
and the end the the season extension is
really great using some of these things
of course we have we started using high
tunnels at the station in 2008 we put up
our first set of about a half an acre of
these are hay grove high tunnels you see
they're multi bay they're interconnected
these are seasonal so the plastic comes
off in the winter time it goes back up
in the spring and for raspberries these
this step in production technology has
really changed the raspberry industry
all it does is keep the rain off but a
raspberry that gets rained on in the
field has a shelf life of about two days
takes four days by truck to get from
California to New York so if they get
rained on even though it doesn't rain a
lot in California it does rain sometimes
although in the last few years not very
often those fruit are unsellable put
them under tunnels where they don't get
wet you get a shelf life of ten to
twelve days so there aren't very many
technology you can use to get a five to
six hundred percent increase in your
shelf life so it's really important for
raspberries because they're so
perishable we also find the plants grow
better the fruits bigger and the yields
are higher all good things
you do have to irrigate for the
commercial market for the supermarket in
California all raspberries are grown
under high tunnels there is no open
field production that's that way they
can guarantee the quality and they can
provide a consistent product that we
expect to see in the supermarkets every
day now doesn't always work out the way
you like
this is Hurricane Ike in 2008 about a
day and a half after we finished putting
the plastic on and it came right over
the top of us 70 mile an hour winds and
tore it up pretty good two weeks later
we had it rebuilt put back together so
it looked really bad that day we
disassembled it parts that were bent
straighten some of them out replace some
of them and we were back in business in
a few days so it really did look bad
Monday morning they'll come into work
what's pretty disheartening we hold
field days then some of the variety
trials we have all the fruit bring
people in to taste it so we put you can
see we put all this fruit out so that
people can sample it see the difference
between the varieties growers come in
they see how we're growing it it's just
a way to get direct outreach and to get
direct input from the growers on what
they like so some of the you came early
you saw in the back I put out some
raspberries so there was a little score
sheet too I figured I have a captive
audience I might as well get some
information out of it but that's the
type of thing will do will provide
grower samples let them taste them let
them rate them on what they think about
raspberries or strawberries - and it
turns out people don't all like the same
thing
generally the good tasting varieties do
separate out that most people like and
then there's often the outliers people
who like tart berries the really sour
ones and that's fairly common in
raspberries to have acidic fruit that is
that it's tart in flavor but generally
the market has moved towards sweet so
higher sugar bigger and redder hopefully
Colin was able to bring some fruit down
in Geneva and they got some to eat I
don't I didn't put any score sheets out
for him but I didn't didn't want to
leave you out for fruit if you're not
seeing it it should be there too Colin
didn't bring it then I'll talk to him
later Colin is my technician so it's my
how I get anything done a little bit
about the statistics berry since I've
been at Cornell so when I came to
Cornell the strawberry industry in the
United States as a whole was about a 1
billion dollar industry on about 46,000
acres the vast majority of those
acreages are in California that part has
not changed now there's about fifty nine
thousand acres this was 2015 data forty
thousand of those acres are in
California the other 19 thousand acres
are spread across the country about half
of that in Florida and the rest spread
out around the country New York is is
fifth in production in acreage in
strawberry production in the US and that
is a very small fifth 2.2 billion
dollars in the US and farm gate value
1.8 billion of that comes out of
California it gives you an idea of the
scope of the industry there it is a
year-round industry they're producing
strawberries pretty much somewhere in
California pretty much year-round now
raspberries is really where we've seen
the real dramatic changes since I've
been here so in 2000 or in 1999 the
process industry has stayed the same
that's pretty much Washington a little
bit in Oregon the values has gone up a
little bit you can see 104 million in
2015 on a slightly fewer hey that is a
machine harvested industry for frozen
primarily it's very concentrated on
three or four varieties that they use
some are produced in the summer with a
very specific training system for the
machine harvest where we see the real
advance is in the fresh market in 1999
California had about 1800 acres of
raspberries in 2015 it was up to eighty
eight hundred acres for fresh market
raspberries the USDA only takes
statistics on California that tells you
what the rest of the country doesn't
even register in there
statistics and the value has risen from
31 million in 1999 to 400 almost 500
million dollars worth out of California
and that's just California if you think
about where raspberries and strawberries
are grown we have Mexico just to the
south and there's a tremendous amount of
fruit that comes from there as well as
far as New York the industry has been
flat for them pretty much the last 20
years worth of statistics in 99 we had
about 1,600 acres in 2015 they only
registered 960 acres across the region
that is the top states that produce the
varieties that we produce here that cold
climate Michigan Ohio Pennsylvania and
such is about 6800 acres in 99 now only
about 3800 acres as far as the
statistics that collects our concern the
value stayed pretty much the same so
what's changed obviously raspberries we
have seen a five-fold increase in
acreage and a 15 fold increase in value
in fresh red raspberries and it is
specifically fresh red raspberries we're
talking about and now they are shiftings
go to any supermarket pretty much any
day of the year you'll see raspberries
of course you know the names Driscoll's
is the biggest name in raspberries and
there have driven that industry
tremendously there's increased berry
production in Mexico as well the vast
majority of blackberries are coming out
of Mexico there's a particular variety
that works very well can be manipulated
to produce fruit most of the year of
course labors
is very affordable there and they can
ship the berries they hold very well and
they're shipping them into the US but in
the u.s. blackberry production has not
increased nearly as much as the other
berries although we're starting to see
that change
the thing that's changed for New York is
the locally grown movement in 1999 there
were only about our 2000 there was only
about 230 farmers markets only I say in
New York now there's over 500 and that
trend continues nationwide that trend
continues as well over 7800 farmers
markets you go to farmers markets in
this area there's almost always berries
locally grown
but those acreages are rarely caught in
the statistics because they're very
small acreage is a half acre 1/4 acre
quarter acre of raspberries can be a lot
of raspberries to take care of and so
sometimes they don't even make it into
the statistics because when those sheets
come out that they have to fill out and
they're growing 14 different crops
because they've got green beans and
they've got pumpkins and they've got
sweet corn and they've got everything
else they're growing the berries don't
even register on their on their
statistics so we know people are growing
berries in New York our berry growers
beginning berry growing
workshops that we hold are packed with
people excited about growing berries you
can do it on a very small scale and
still produce enough berries to have
some money to make some money and so
it's just one one crop within a many
crops that many of these farmers are
growing so these small grower statistics
are really difficult to capture in the
USDA's overall statistic picture the
other thing that's changed then with
these farmers markets and the locally
grown movement is that people are more
interested in distinctive varieties for
these markets the supermarket has gone
towards one thing big and red that's
they want big red raspberries big red
strawberries and that's pretty much
where the market place is when you go to
the supermarket you know they look great
in the container but sometimes the
eating quality is not where you'd really
like it when you go to a farmers market
you want a high quality berry you want a
high flight flavor berry and you don't
want what you can get in the supermarket
so I want a big red raspberry that
doesn't taste very good I can go to the
supermarket so when people go to farmers
markets sometimes they want something a
little different
so in my program and of course we still
want to produce a big red raspberry
because our California collaborators
they still want those for the
supermarket so this is a variety we put
out a few years ago big and red flavors
adequate ships very well so you got a
balance what you're trying to do with a
variety you know with strawberries this
is Archer if you have it you'll see some
pictures in it and probably it's a very
large red berry this one happens to be
very high flavor as well it's a little
softer than oats you'll find in the
supermarket so we're hoping for the
local market people will enjoy this as
well nice to pick Phil's containers
really fast people really like that both
for you pick and for pre picked well we
also have some darker berries that we've
put out so here you'll see on on my
right is purple wonder that's being sold
through Burpee it's much darker than you
an average strawberry would be and that
color carries through all the way
through the flesh so it is a dark
fleshed berry as well a juice comes out
of it looking like wine it's that that
dark but the commercial market really
doesn't know what to do with something
like that does it fit into any of their
marketing schemes
so you see Burpee has a nice display on
it at their website as you notice over
here they're selling them for ten
dollars and ninety five cents a piece
per plant the commercial grower grows by
strawberry plants for about thirteen to
fifteen cents apiece so it gives you an
idea what the retail market will bear
when it comes to specialty varieties I
had no part in deciding what the cost of
these would be Burpee did that on their
own but we get a very small portion of
that as royalties back to the to the
University
there are regulations on shipping plants
sometimes California certainly has a lot
of regulations on you can't ship certain
species I don't know about all of these
states some of those are not States so
there must be some some territories
involved there as well and it may be
they don't want to ship some of these
places as well but certainly California
you have to inspect plants for instance
for Japanese beetles before you can ship
plants there so there are there are
things like that that would be my my
guest there Westover white strawberry so
that's one there you see in the catalogs
listed as pine berry white flesh red
seeds tastes like a strawberry really
just a novelty but it's interesting
really not something for the commercial
market for the for the retail market
it fits something that people like to do
because they like to tinker in their
gardens they like to pick stuff and show
their neighbors you know look what I did
you know you've never seen anything like
this so it's very popular in that kind
of market but again it's a very small
portion of what we do some of the darker
raspberries crimson night that was the
one I put over on the table with the
refreshments dark dark fruited very
sweet freezes very well much darker than
what you see in the supermarket and then
a peach colored one double gold again
novelty it's what people like flavors
very high a little on the soft side if
you had some back there so it doesn't
shift particularly well but it eats well
and people really like it and it in your
back yard it's very interesting to look
at as well as eat
we work a little bit in purple primarily
we're working in purple because we're
trying to transfer traits from red into
purple and into black sorry when you
cross a black raspberry in a red
raspberry the fruits purple so we're
trying to transfer thornless which we
have done and we're trying to transfer
fall bearing as well which is in the
middle stages for that so some of the
stuff we're looking at but if we were to
get a purple that was interesting we
certainly be there is some market for it
and in the retail market yellow
there's lesser interest in yellow pretty
much a novelty makes it look interesting
when you have a fruit salad but they
pretty much taste like red raspberry so
most people will choose red when you
give but we want to put out a yellow one
just to have a complete suite of
varieties this is not one we're working
on this is what you'll find on the
internet people say oh I want blue
raspberry flavor I'd say that's not a
real flavor so these are not the kind of
berries we're growing and we really wish
that blue raspberry flavor would go away
but it is something I actually do get
asked about fairly often so the breeding
program today is traditional breeding
crossbreed we choose parents transfer
pollen collect seed grow out plants it's
a very straightforward process that's
been going on for centuries we work in
strawberry both short day which are
their June bears that we scroll mostly
in New York and the day neutral that
more interest that we'll provide that
exceeds an extension in those low
tunnels raspberry both black and red
again flora keen is for summer
production start somewhere in June will
produce through most of July and prime
mccain's starting in July and produce
into the fall through until it gets too
cold with black berry I mentioned
traditional blackberries fruit in the
summer they don't do well in New York
because they generally freeze the Canes
freeze you don't get a reliable crop so
what john mckean Clark University of
Arkansas started this a number of years
ago to work with blackberries that would
fruit in the fall so you can avoid
winter and we've been doing some work
with him and now on our own to bring
that flowering time early enough into
the season so that we can flower in July
in August and have fruit
in August September October for
blackberries and the blackberries are
brought back there today were picked
yesterday so we're at some of the new
selections from the program are in full
harvest and we're getting a very nice
product yield is still a little bit on
the low side it's something we're
working on but some yield is better than
no yield which is what we generally get
with summer bearing types so expect to
see more blackberry production in in the
northern climates in the coming in the
coming years and they are starting to
adapt this tech these types of varieties
in California as well for blackberry
production so they can time the
plantings to get fruit at a certain
number of days after planting on the
current year's growth without a dormancy
period and that's really the advance you
don't eat dormancy we'll talk a little
bit then you can very faint some of the
molecular genetic projects as the other
side of the program so I thought I'd get
asked a lot about you know how long does
it take to get a variety out you know
what is the process so I thought I'd
walk you through what we did with Archer
my newest strawberry and it is it can be
a long process so the archer was a
selection I made very early in my career
here at Cornell and it was done very
much in the traditional sense of things
and so you'll see every step was done
through the field on a year-by-year
basis and it takes a long time doing it
that way so we've got some strategies
we've worked on and we'll talk about how
we've been speeding that up but this is
how Archer started so in 99 we made some
crosses made some hybridizations
I didn't have a lot of information to go
on I hadn't worked on berries for very
long but we had the records from my
patent from the pass breeder and we made
some crosses collected the seed in 2000
that seed got treating got planted out
into the field and you just grow them in
the field so we planted them in rows and
let them grow those have to grow a year
go through winter the next spring we get
to see fruit
now we've cleaned that up a little bit
we use plastic we put them on plastic to
help with weed control but the process
is generally the same we put them in the
ground one spring the next spring we get
to see fruit helps as well we use a
little bit of raised beds when you get a
lot of water this year that didn't
happen but last year we had water it was
so high it wet almost over the beds so
from some years we get a lot of rain and
some years you get none but you can't
know that in advance so in 2001 we made
the selection so this is a 2001
selection I made some notes that day
when I selected it it's a huge King
berry often the primary barrier that
comes off a strawberry in the industry
they'll call it the king berry I put
very large q well I use the term Queen
berry as well rather than secondary
because it's easier to write but that's
not generally used in the industry and I
wrote that it was firmed a good interior
color good flavor tart that's what I had
to go on I made some notes that day and
I picked three fruit a primary barrier
she a secondary barrier and a tertiary
berry you add those up it's almost a
hundred grams of fruit so I calculated
if you took a hundred grams of fruit
which is only three berries per plant on
a per acre basis that's over four
thousand pounds each plant produces more
than three fruit so this is the kind of
thing when we see this kind of thing
we're like it Wow we got yield right
away because we got a lot of fruit size
it comes off very quickly and it comes
off at once
and for us to have a tertiary berry and
the 16 gram size is a very good berry in
the marketplace 25 will get you about
this big 55 or 50 grams will be about
the size of a plum that's a very large
berry that's larger than what you
normally see and we like will pick
berries down to about 8 to 10 grams is
acceptable for a commercial product so
that year we had one plant that's all
there is is one plant from that one seed
so whatever runners it produced we
collected those runners routed them and
start and when there's a picture from
that first plant they're not the
prettiest things I'm out there holding
them with one hand taking a picture with
the other so it's really not I'm not a
photographer but it for me it gets it in
my head so I can look back and say
I remember that one and that's what we
do to have a picture of kind of a record
as we go you start a plot whether it
took the year to make the runners then
you plant them again you gotta wait
another year before they fruit again so
that takes a year we planted and then we
look at it for two or three years
because we want to see is it gonna live
it's gonna have some disease that wipes
it out in the first second year it's a
fruit gonna grow or the plants going to
grow are they going to produce runners
so we collect more runners from the next
plot and then you plant another plot and
you do it again to make sure because you
got a planet in different locations to
make sure you didn't plant it in the
best possible location and it was great
but in a bad location it's gonna die
very quickly so we planted multiple
plots at different locations so that we
can see this over time and then you have
to evaluate it for several years to see
how it comes through winter to see how
the plants grow will they persist in the
field will it have a good yield every
year it takes time to go through this
and it can really take a long time and
during that way most of the selections
gets left off they're found wanting for
whatever reason they're susceptible to
some disease they don't produce enough
runners the fruit quality declines over
time these are things that you see we
take more pictures so we all make sure
we're planting the same plant every time
and that when you it produces fruit the
fruit looks like what we think it's
supposed to look like so each time you
each cycle you're taking pictures to
make sure everything is the same at that
point we decided these are looking good
they're very consistent we're gonna move
it in a tissue culture because to take
it off the station we need disease-free
plants I can't collect stuff from the
field and send it out to growers or to a
nursery and it could have any kind of
pathogen on it so we move it into tissue
culture to clean it up make sure it
doesn't have any viruses make sure it
doesn't have by top syrup verticillium
various fungal pathogens and that takes
can take it a few months but it could
take a year or more to some some
varieties don't tissue culture wealth
so we got plants we have to check in for
virus we have to produce more plants so
we can put them back out in the field
make sure tissue culture didn't screw it
up sometimes you put things in tissue
culture what you get out of tissue
culture doesn't look like what you put
in and so we have to make sure that we
grow plants make sure they're true to
type make sure they look like what you
expect them to look like all this takes
time and we of course take more pictures
we want to make sure it looks like it's
supposed to look like you have to make
sure you have the same product that you
in the end with what you started with so
we confirmed trueness type at that stage
we're like okay we got virus free plants
let's send it to the nursery so they can
propagate it in large numbers that way
we can get it to some of the growers so
in 2014 we sent out 16,000 plus plants
to different 11 growers across the state
so they could grow it in a large scale
and give me some feedback on how how it
looks for them how is it looking at
commercial setting up and at that point
we had 25 foot plots at the biggest you
know so now they get a thousand plants
or 2,000 plants and you can see it on a
eighth of an acre a quarter of an acre
and actually see it in a large scale
they evaluated the first year they
evaluate it again the second year if you
want to sit most of the growers will
grow it in a perennial setting and they
want to see it more than one year so all
this takes 15 years we get to this point
and we're finally okay it's time to
release it and you're here today it's
being released today it's being
announced so it is available to growers
now they won't plant it until next year
but of course we're taking pictures all
along to make sure that it's the same
thing
question
yes
so what the growers will pay what the
growers will do or what the nursery will
charge is a propagation fee so that the
cost of propagation is offset so it is
not the same price that is its we're not
selling the plants they're offsetting
the cost of propagation
it's a semantics but it is not available
to commercial growers in this case was
only available to growers of the New
York State berry Growers Association
through a cooperative agreement with
Cornell University that we have with the
Association so we didn't send it to just
any growers we sent it to growers who
were part of this organization that we
had a contract with for doing the
testing and so this was this year this
is fruit I got from a commercial grower
it looked great he was happy with it we
moved forward so that it's now gonna be
available and they will plant the first
commercial crop this coming spring in
2017 of course we won't see that fruit
until 2018 so again there's time every
time you have to grow the plant so it
can really take a long time to get
through it so how do we speed up the
process well protected agriculture is
one of those ways certainly the high end
low tunnels speed things up the plants
grow faster you get a better look at the
plants because every year you have a
good year because you can control the
environment much better this year in our
open field the raspberries are very very
short where they're not irrigated they
just didn't grow much because they
didn't get any rain in the tunnels where
it's irrigated and protected the plants
look just like they do every year
they're eight feet tall and they're
covered in fruit and so we can really
get a faster look at things and since we
can look at them quickly we can evaluate
them quickly and move things into the
commercial stream much faster because we
can make decisions based on better
information
we can make that decision quickly and
get them into tissue culture quickly and
once we have them in tissue culture
there are commercial labs we work with
who can propagate them and propagate
thousands of plants very quickly from a
few tissue cultures both raspberry and
strawberry work very well in tissue
culture and so propagation once you have
the culture started goes very rapidly
and in raspberry it is commonly done in
in the commercial nurseries that people
will use tissue culture for propagation
we've what the other thing we've done is
sped up the grower evaluations rather
than waiting until that last stage to
get up to growers we're really trying to
get it to the growers much sooner so
this year in New York we sent some 2012
selections to a couple of growers in
really preliminary trials but to skip
commercials look at them much earlier in
the process only four years from when it
was selected versus ten or twelve years
after it was selected some of our
commercial growers are larger growers so
we do that with the New York State berry
Growers Association some of our other
co-operators in larger locations larger
industry locations they want they want
new stuff as fast as they can get it so
sometimes one or two years after its
selected they'll get up take a look at
it because they're really interested in
moving very quickly and they have the
infrastructure to give me feedback very
very rapidly and so that's one of the
things we're doing to try and speed
things up
long term we'd like to do some marker
assisted selection using genetics and
and DNA technology to speed up the
process and make it more efficient throw
out the stuff that isn't worthy before
it ever makes it to the field but we're
a long way from that so one of the
things we're doing in the tunnel is
growing things in pots so in the field
when we plant a seedling it usually has
to grow at least 18 months before we can
see fruit the summer types need to grow
for two years before we can see fruit
these fall types in a high tunnel and
pots we can plant them in the greenhouse
in March bring them out in the pots in
May into the tunnels and their fruiting
now so between march and now we get to
see fruit and we can eliminate a lot of
stuff that is unsuitable now we can't
make great decisions on the stuff that
looks best
but we can move it much faster and
eliminates a lot of the stuff that were
not interested in and so this is one of
the things that we're we're starting to
do more of so in a high tunnel like this
it's 24 feet wide we could fit about 900
potted plants and so we can go through
900 plants a year in there and those in
the field those might be in the field
for 3 or 4 years for each cycle to look
at them so traditional breeding which we
were doing before in the molecular
genetic side of things we've done quite
a bit of genetic mapping we've done some
marker-assisted selection we've got
smart AC quark and genome sequencing to
try and increase the level of
information that we have for the
genetics of raspberry and for the future
we'd like to try the you know the latest
thing that everybody wants to try is
CRISPR but we think there's some really
interesting things that can be done in
clonally propagated crops with this
technology and since raspberry works so
well in tissue culture it's a fairly
natural thing to try it on because it is
usually done in tissue culture so we've
done some genetic mapping and rasberry
primarily for Phytophthora root rot
resistance so if i top there as a
disease of the soil of the roots that's
in the soil it's pretty devastating on
raspberries it's very persistent
there is good resistance but most of the
resistance are in varieties that aren't
particularly useful for the commercial
market so we'd like to do breeding and
you can do breeding and you can do field
of analysis but if it doesn't rain you
don't get by top Zura so it's hard to
screen stuff in the field for fight tops
or resistance if you have a dry climate
or if you have a dry year like we did
this year we had lots of problems on
raspberries this year but if I talked or
was not one of them because we didn't
have a lot of infection
so how do you look at if I talk there
then in us in a way that is consistent
well we developed a hydroponic system so
we could actually observe the roots in
the raspberry as the disease is
developing so that we could get an
accurate screen of resistance and then
we developed methyl molecular markers
gets genetic map and then look for QTL
analysis the quantitative traits so if I
top through a resistance in raspberry is
a multi gene trait a quantitative trait
and you look for qtls
to try to figure out where in the genome
most they influence on that trait it's
coming from so here's the hydroponic
system you can see when there is no
pathogen raspberry likes it very well it
grows very well the root systems are
white and healthy but once you introduce
the pathogen very quickly a parent which
ones are susceptible and which ones are
resistant so it gives us an accurate
screen to use for our genetic mapping
and we've been able to use this and
you'll see multiple times in different
aspects of this project so this work was
was done by one of my graduate students
Jeremy Patterson who now works for
Driscoll strawberry associates in
California and so you can see that
genetic map there's seven half-light
haploid number and in raspberry a7 we
have seven linkage groups we looked at
the disease in different ways we took a
qualitative score just one to five is it
diseased or not diseased and then we
looked at stem lesions so they develop
stem lesions as the plant is infected
and you can measure how how big those
are some of the petioles get lesions so
you can do a percentage of the petioles
that get lesions and then you can take a
route score as well since we can observe
the roots directly when you do a potted
study and the roots are surrounded by
soil you get dead or not dead but it's
very hard to tell what's going on in the
roots and so this way we are able to
look at the roots directly and get a
score there and we found that all four
of those traits mapped to two regions so
turn tells us that when we're measuring
these things all of them were a good
measure of resistance and that they were
measuring essentially the same thing
that same level of disease rosetta
zees development and then the percentage
of the variation that was explained by
the various scores so some of them quite
a bit when you combine the two locations
50% of the variation was defined by that
score only 25% with a stem lesion so it
wasn't as as consistent you'll see 55
and so on so what but these regions of
the genome are very clearly have
something to do with with resistance the
problem is that that it's when you start
looking at the sequence that's a very
large amount of sequence and so there's
quite a few genes in that region that
you would have to look at we publish
some of this work and tag some years ago
it was it was later confirmed by another
group in Scotland that they published a
very similar work that came up with the
same conclusions which we were very
gratified to see there are competitors
we have stunts a marker system selection
with those markers in those regions we
screened varieties we put varieties in
there and introduced it and and looked
at both the markers and the resistance
rating from this and it did pretty well
when we did the Marga it's about 76%
accurate and what we found is that when
the resistance came from a different
background the markers kind of broke
down so the background the markers we
found followed a resistance from a
specific source and there are other
sources in the germ plasm that are
probably not in the same area or at
least have different markers if they are
in that area when we looked at
populations so seedling populations was
all over the place so some of the
seedling populations that were of the
same source very very accurate 90
percent are better but some of the
populations that came from sources of
resistance that we didn't know that
we're not from the resistant latham some
of them were worse than flipping a coin
so the markers didn't always work across
the populations and that's one of the
things we find very commonly in
marker-assisted selection that they're
very population specific the markers and
so so what do we do we want to find
better markers that would be a good
thing we keep
new markers work or we can continue to
look at other populations or we could
try to use some other genomic tools so
the marketer assisted selection work
we've presented some of this work at
international conferences and and
publish that there but we wanted to look
a little deeper into the question of
what is actually happening why what
genes are turned on why is resistance
happening so we looked at we wanted to
use RNA seek or RNA sequencing we took
root tissue from Latham which is the
resistance to set variety and Titan
which is susceptible variety and we did
a pre and post disease so we wanted to
look at what genes were turned on before
I had any disease and then what happened
when you introduced a disease into the
plant if you're not interested not
familiar with RNA seek RNA seek is a way
to capture the RNA at a specific time
point so it isn't really you're not
following at over time but you grab the
RNA from a tissue and isolate it and
that tells you what's going on at that
moment and then in this case we grabbed
it at another moment as well and
compared the two moments so you break
them up into small pieces because at the
time the technology was we were at 86
base pairs or nucleotides with what
could be sequence using Illumina turn it
into DNA sequence it and then you have
millions of little fragments and they
have to help be all pieced together
there's quite a few computer programs
that they do this with it helps if you
have a genome a reference genome that's
already be there because you can
reference those sequences straight to
the genome but if you don't you can put
it together just like a jigsaw puzzle
where you don't have the picture and
you're just trying to piece it together
bit by bit and of course this is done
with computers to look at every possible
combination to see what lines up you get
more accurate when you have a genome but
sometimes you don't have that especially
with crops like raspberry where there is
no genome published it's not a widely
who study genome or plant so there
really isn't quite the resources you
would have for a bit off sis or rice or
corn or one of the more studied crops we
actually did both with that
but so again we took the hydroponic
system we collected RNA from the roots
which is very difficult to do when
they're in a pot covered with soil so
this hydroponic system came back into it
so we could collect fresh root tissue
and then diseased root tissue so you
could see the difference between the
susceptible ones and the resistant ones
in the at the RNA level at the gene
expression level so we've reported on
this at pag and a few other and rubra
striae symposium so what did we do we
had about 71 million reads of 86
nucleotides which is fairly typical kind
of number overall once we looked at all
the we identified approximately 17,000
genes that were expressed in these
tissues of course all kinds of genes are
expressed and they may or may not be
related to resistance we we took between
the two groups between Titan and Latham
and there was a lot of overlap about
13,000 genes and then we did an
alignment both to diploid sorry diploid
strawberry which was pretty much the
closest genome that we had as a
reference genome and then we did de novo
as well just the one without a picture
when you just try and piece it together
based on the sequence you have this work
was done by another graduate student
Judd Ward also works for Driscoll
strawberry associate he is there ahead
of their genome department now and then
we did a differential expression
analysis look at the genes between the
two groups to see what was different
that's what that the assembly was done
how to do it in non model plants we
published that in the journal of botany
has been very well received because
there's a lot of crops that people have
very little genome data to work with
they don't have a reference genome when
it's like well how do we how do we deal
with us are all this RNA seek data and
so we put that out so what did we find
we pretty much in both of them you know
infect them with red with Phytophthora
and all their defense genes turn on
everything they have
goes nuts but there's some differential
expression so some of these things were
turned on I won't get into the details
of which what the genes are but these
are have to do with affecting the
pathogen and turning on the defense
mechanisms we saw a differential
expression so in Titan they weren't
turned on as much there's susceptible
one as they were in in late them so
upregulation a very key defensive genes
the PR genes are pathogenesis related
these are genes that are often turned on
and expressed when a plant is trying to
fight off a pathogen of some sort and
there's a bunch of these genes we found
eighteen different ones that were
expressed in Lathan ten of them were
upregulated and latham or only ten were
upregulated and Titan and three of them
were actually down regulated and Titan
very different expression pattern of
these defense responsive genes between
the two types between the resistant and
the susceptible but of course we still
these are large numbers of genes that
we're looking at we did a blast search
of the of the data just using the terms
salicylic acid jazz monic acids systemic
acquired resistance defense disease
these are all terms that are used to
describe genes and so when we did that
what ninety nine different things came
up 99s a lot of things to choose from
this is the kind of stuff you get from
blast so we could tell though these were
genes that were actually differentially
expressed in the resistant type so in
Latham so in the control versus the
treatment you can see the number goes up
because it's expressed more great more
highly in in the resistant or when the
pathogen is actually present and you see
here then these are just the search
terms that you use and and what pops up
from the blast searches and this table
went on for page after page after page
because all the information so you have
to sort through all this figure out what
you what you what you're working with so
where do you go with this I mean 99 is
better than 17,000 but we still can't
actually do you know candidate gene work
on 99 different genes it's just not
possible with the with the funding I
have and the technology that we have now
it would take a long time and a big team
to do it so some of the things you can
rule out fairly quickly they're very
specific responses versus very broad
responses so some of them are about you
know producing lignin in the in the
cells and that may not have any direct
response but is a kind of a side
response to this so we can we can start
to to to rule some of that stuff out
then we want to align it to the G the
genome to the qtls that we have so that
we can start looking just in the region
where the qtls are rather than looking
through all the genome and focus on
those first the genes that might be
might be present in those regions and
that's at the stage where we're at now
analyzing the genome data that we have
with the RNA seek data to try and narrow
down our choices and then once we start
figuring out what might be there that's
where the CRISPR would come in now
CRISPR is something know that right now
not a lot of people don't have a lot of
experience with myself included but we
think there's some targets in raspberry
that we can use to learn how to use a
technique and make it possible
useful in the future you're not familiar
with CRISPR it's a bacterial system that
they theorize is used in protecting the
bacteria from viral infection primarily
if you wondering what the acronym stands
for they're clustered regularly
interspaced short palindromic repeats
that's CRISPR tells you a lot doesn't it
they are specific DNA sequences in the
bacterial genome that the bacteria can
use to target alongside this CRISPR
associated protein 9 it forms a complex
and it can find the foreign DNA in its
own genome and systematically or
very specifically cut it out and get rid
of the pathogenic DNA DNA that's what we
feel that's what scientists think that
the actual system does in in nature what
they've done is it's harming assists to
take this section here which is that
targeted DNA and put in one that you you
want to change yourself so make up make
this DNA molecule yourself so that you
could target a very specific DNA
sequence that you want to change now to
do that though you have to know the very
specific DNA sequence that you want to
change and it's a very small piece of
DNA that you want to change so it's
really very challenging to get to that
point but my new student Archana is
working on this project we're going to
do some of this work with thornless
because we think a simple trait that we
can very easily visually work with and
and classify is what we're going to work
on so we have a population that's that's
segregating we'll do some sequencing to
try and find the gene for thornless and
then try to use CRISPR to work on the
thornless gene because we can do this in
tissue culture we can very rapidly
phenotype them as the process goes
forward
at the end of this in the end then we
want to transfer that to fly top throw
work as we narrow down the different
genes that could possibly be interested
in fight off their resistance that yeah
I mentioned my couple of my former
students both working for Driscoll's
bill Boone was a technician in my
program for many years and Colin is my
current technician without him I don't
have a chance to get a whole lot done
and of course Archana will be working
with me for the next several years on
this CRISPR project we're very excited
to see where that goes so in a nutshell
there's the berry breeding at Cornell if
there are any questions I would be
around 15 minutes the question about it
me not mentioning organic organic is
very challenging thing for berries
because they're very very perishable
they have a lot of things that like
to eat them besides humans er it's even
more difficult because all the rain so
without these fungicides it's very
challenging to get organic this new
passed ball spotted wing Drosophila over
200 fruit fly is causing any more
trouble with it most organic production
right now is growing a dry climate
locations and they're using organic
pesticides to try to control that fly
nutrition is very difficult as well in
these systems with organic fertilizers
because they don't work well in to
irrigation systems so we don't do a lot
of organic raspberry or strawberry
doctors in New York
just because of the challenges of the
environment
question I'm just curious if you'd look
at the nutritional profile
chemical profiles of the raspberry
coatings the question was about looking
at phytochemical and nutritional
differences amongst varieties we have
done a fair bit of work in that area
both here and then the collaboration
with North Carolina State they have a
lab that does a lot of that work we find
wide ranges of certainly management
content phenolic content among some
berries they're all very high though
even the yellow ones are very high in
phenolic compounds even though they have
no pigment defined by Bonet folic acid
vitamin C host of things in general
berries are good for you
and want people to eat more of them not
necessarily specific ones so but there's
a lot of published work on the
differences among some right
any questions in Geneva I've kept you
there long
in your RNA seek work did you choose a
time point slantwise
English
and so in our studies that heard the
question and our studies before in doing
the analysis of inheritance we were able
to observe the routing systems as the
pathogen was introduced in the disease
progressed and so we used our experience
from that to choose a time point while
absolutely at zero time point before the
pathogen and then we actually took
sample set at two days six days and
thirty days and those were very distinct
time points in the inheritance study at
two days there was no symptoms yet but
there was infection and so we could
measure that there was infection in the
plan at six days you start seeing
symptoms and at 30 days you start seeing
grow back of the booths that are in the
resistant plants so we didn't have that
last time point the susceptible ones
because they're all dead but we were
able to then choose those points so that
we can see the progression of the
disease
not only in the plant but in the
as far as a better tissue it seems that
for Phytophthora that the resistance is
in the root system is expressed in the
root system so I think that's the best
tissue better to use though it is
somewhat challenging to use that we use
we can use the same for the varieties
are these varieties related to each
other at this point we want to stay with
the varieties that we've been using
because we have so much historical data
on those varieties certainly there are
other sources of resistance that we
would like to look at in the future but
can only do so much because we know
there are sources that are not relating
to this this source that we're using but
at this point we don't have plans to use
other
types so our time is up thank professor
Weber for this has been a production of
Cornell University on the web at Cornell
edu